what's up everybody
so today II W gifted us a first look at
Captain Marvel and it was truly amazing
super excited now for the movie even
more so than I was before if you did not
catch my video on it don't worry I'll be
showing you all the photos in this video
but if you want the full breakdown you
can check it out in the link above also
I'm doing an Avengers infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so shortly after they
released the cover page for their latest
issue that had Captain Marvel on the
cover they came out and released eleven
more exclusive photos so I'm going to
show you these photos and break them
down for you
so this first photo here is titled meet
Marvel's newest star and right below it
it says paging Carol Danvers it's really
interesting that it says that because it
makes me think could this photo be where
Carol Danvers Captain Marvel shows up to
earth and responds to Nick Fury's page
she does look ready to go she clearly
isn't happy you can see it on the
expression on her face her fists are
both clenched so perhaps this is right
when she arrives and is ready to fight
somebody this next photo is titled a
force to be reckoned with and it is
awesome so what we've learned from this
photo is that this is where the movie is
going to start off it's going to start
off with Carol Danvers already having
her powers and already being a part of
the military team star force she also
will not be on earth she will be on the
Kree planet Halle this photo is crazy
cool because you can see her team here
which is essentially a SEAL Team 6
that's how it's described and in her
team you can see Korath from guardians
of the galaxy min irva and on the left
you can see Ronan this is our first look
at Ronan in Captain Marvel and right
behind him you can see Jude Law standing
there don't worry there's a more awesome
photo of Ronan coming up but speaking of
Jude Law let's talk about this next
picture it's titled a mysterious mint
or Jude Law plays the commander of Star
Force and views Carol Danvers as a pet
project and a mentee Jude Law and the
interview with Entertainment Weekly said
these extraordinary powers she has he
sees them as something of a blessing and
something that she has to learn how to
control that's a motive throughout the
piece the element of learning to control
one's emotions and to use your powers
wisely this next picture is awesome we
see the scrolls for the very first time
titled mean and green they are some of
Marvel's most nastiest and most
notorious shape-shifting villains and
speaking of shape-shifting this next
photo is titled double duty and is
actually of the scroll leader Talos and
in Captain Marvel Talos will go
undercover as a human working with
shield this is probably the coolest
photo released and it's called familiar
faces and you see Ronin super excited to
see him back in guardians of the galaxy
Ronan is an outcast with extremist views
but in Captain Marvel
he's just a high-ranking member of Kree
society and of course Jude Law next to
him in his Kree uniform we've actually
seen a picture of Carol Danvers wearing
this uniform as well in this next photo
we can see Carol Danvers rocking some
90s clothes because this is titled
totally 90s because it is set in the 90s
and if you look closely enough you can
see that she's wearing a Nine Inch Nails
shirt this next photo is really awesome
as well you can see here we have a young
Nick Fury this photo is titled fire and
fury he is much younger than we've ever
seen him he has both eyes and in Captain
Marvel he's not the director of shield
he's just a desk jockey so perhaps we'll
see him climb up the ranks of shield and
Captain Marvel this next one is called
ready for takeoff and it shows Carol
Danvers inside of a fighter plane before
she became Captain Marvel Carol Danvers
was actually an Air Force pilot she's
going to start the movie off with her
powers but no doubts that they'll be
doing some flashbacks to go over the
origin of how she got her powers this
next photo introduces a new character
and is titled flying high this
Maria Rambo and one of Carole's oldest
friends and also a top-notch Air Force
pilot with the callsign Photon
Maria is also a single mother with a
young daughter and of course the last
one they shared is Captain Marvel smack
dab right in the middle of Entertainment
Weekly's cover again it looks amazing
the suit looks amazing brie Larson looks
like Captain Marvel I can't wait to see
the movie I can't wait to see her in
Avengers 4 I think she's going to do a
great job as Captain Marvel and I think
overall an amazing character to
introduce into the MCU so there you go a
walkthrough of all the new images that
Entertainment Weekly released let me
know what you all think of them in the
comments below also if you would like to
learn more about Captain Marvel check
out my video at the end that explains
her origin and powers and another
reminder about the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway I'm doing if you would like to
enter all you have to do is be a
subscriber to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]